virtual chair
will you marry me
and make me the happiest man in this
world
I like that that of course is a hit film
crazy Rich Asians it's based on the New
York Times bestselling book of the very
same name may you may not know is Asian
American and Pacific Islander heritage
month and Amazon books editorial
director Sarah gellman is here to share
her top books to celebrate good morning
Sarah always good to have you good
morning thanks for having me so you say
first up you've got an epic novel about
history love and betrayal that you say
crushed it in a good way I was yes my
heart broke but in a great way so this
is the great Reclamation by Rachel hang
it takes place in Singapore and if your
idea of modern day Singapore is crazy
Rich Asians you absolutely have to read
this book it is about the great
Reclamation refers to the land
reclamation project that happened in
Singapore between the 1960s and the
1990s so 25 of what is modern day in
Singapore was actually ocean before like
it's land now and this book is a novel
about a young boy from a coastal fishing
Village and it's it's a love story it's
a coming of age story it's about the
loss of innocence and the thing I love
the most about this book and I love a
lot of things about it is it manages to
be about the biggest things and the
smallest things all at once I picked
this for my Sarah selects book club last
month and one thing I heard from readers
is this wouldn't be a book they'd
normally pick up but they absolutely
loved it and is that the most rewarding
thing is this feels like a classic in
the making I love seeing that wow that's
that's High Praise speaking of big
things and small things continued in one
book you also have a book about a small
town mall that closes and all the big
connection within it right I mean it is
about that but I think saying it's about
a mall closing is like saying that Moby
Dick is about a whale it's full that's
bold I understand that this is about
what's the internet of it it's called
you are here Karen Lynn Greenberg it's
about the interconnectedness of human
people how we're all really unknowable
to each other and how one event can
absolutely change the trajectory of
someone's life it reminds me of early
Celeste Eng if you're a fan of hers I
love this book it also reminds me of an
apology specifically dear Edward okay so
you recommend a book that grapples with
the question of diversity racism and
cultural appropriation yes so so yellow
face
and isn't that the point it wants you to
feel uncomfortable
like watching a car accident you don't
want to but you can't look away and I
could not put this book down it was a
litter equivalent of a car accident in a
good way a good way
um so the plot you need to describe the
plot the plot is two young female
writers one white one Asian the Asian
one is very successful the white one is
not the Asian one dies and the white one
steals her manuscript which is about
Chinese laborers during World War One
and she decides to make a couple changes
and publish it as her own only under an
ethnically ambiguous author photo and
name and the book takes off but there's
one person out there that knows the
truth and it starts this sort of
literary cat and mouse game it is so
much fun the beauty of you Sarah every
time you come whatever you recommend I'm
thinking I want to read that I want to
read that these are all so good I love
all these books Oprah was here a couple
of days and I was happy to see you had
the coven of water you would pick that
yes you would pick that before I had now
why why did you like it I thought it was
a bit long but I thought it was long but
I also thought it paid off and delivered
yes that's the thing about the book pays
off in delivery it is a lot to ask
someone to read it's like 750 Pages yes
and to me it's like the way that I try
to sell longer books is I say you know
when you start a TV series and you love
it and then you look in their 10 seasons
that is a gift like you get so much time
with these characters and I ached for
these characters
I think I mean everything it's you when
Oprah was talking about breaking it down
into separate sort of mini-series pieces
you so feel that because the characters
are all so real there's so many aspects
of them and there's one character in
particular
um the doctor that I started reading it
and I was like where does he fit in and
then at the end everything ties up it's
like every sentence in that book belongs
it's not bloated I know I know I said no
bro listen not a wasted word no that's
it you call this book a gift it is a
gift I agree I agree like I've said
before find you someone that loves you
that sure loves books I know I do love
books
on your favorite podcast app or scan the
QR code on your screen to start
following us and we will follow you
right on your phone or tablet everywhere
you go we'll be right back